yeah i did my driving test for a manual
car right
and this driving test put me off driving
manual for my entire
[ __ ] life okay so explain i think
you're allowed 16 minor offenses
right this is 60 oh oh my gosh
what registers is a minor offense um
like like not indicating
no no no no that's a major one like like
maybe going a little too early
yeah too much time stuff that doesn't
matter but if you do a lot of them it
would be like you're a [ __ ] rising stuff
that won't cause an accident yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah exactly if your tires
like hit a curb i think that's amazing
that's that's the main major yeah yeah
yeah so like that's the level of
okay yeah okay but like a minor friends
is something that can't cause a crash or
anything like that
i think but i got 13 on my holy [ __ ] i
got 13 on my
driving oh my god i thought i'd failed
right
so i'm gonna test the limit and i swear
like because i was so [ __ ] stressed
it was my first time
it was my first attempt at a driving
test as well and i remember this there
was always
one road i was super [ __ ] terrified
would be on my driving test and
of course it was on my driving test yeah
and so driving a manual
driving a manual car it's a hill start
all right
as well yeah it's a hill start into into
a roundabout
oh same same oh my god like that
i i i remember when i pulled up and
normally i
i hope that the roundabout's [ __ ]
clear of course it's not clear you know
so you're playing you're playing about
five different mini games at once
yeah and if you store the car if you go
too early go too late or do any of that
[ __ ] you fail the test
and that that like the experience of
having to drive manual
and you because with driving manual you
are constantly playing
playing a mini game where i just want to
shut my brain off i want a stress-free
driving experience
um so yeah that's why i i've driven
automatic my entire life since then
basically i've
never driven in automatics i don't know
if it's like really yeah i want to there
it'll be like [ __ ] putting the
antenna on in mario kart
how do i crash how do i crash this dude
on my way to the driving test i did like
everything wrong like i didn't indicate
i ran a red light
i [ __ ] up on a roundabout nearly
caused a crash my driving instructor was
like it's okay if you have to do it
twice
you know it's yeah and then i got like
two miners that's it
i like went in like men mode like focus
i just like killed it
and i was like wow okay damn i'm good at
this for this very small point during
the day where it mattered
it's not as bad as my uncle he like my
uncle like the he failed his first
driving test and
do you want to guess how he failed his
first driving test what are they doing
crash
so like you know when you you do you
start at the dmv like
in your driving test or did you just
start like we start at a random road for
wherever you parked your car i guess
obviously yeah so in australia you start
at the actual dvd and you have to like
go out of the dmv
driver come back to the dmv and then
once you're back at the dmv
then that's the end of the test my uncle
went out of the exit
of the dmv okay so he got in the car he
started it up
drove out two seconds later he was like
you failed why
because he drove out of the exit oh oh
sorry he drove out of the entrance
that sounds that sounds better than what
happens in the uk in the uk
if you do a major like major mistake
you know you've done it you have to
complete the test oh really they don't
tell you you failed immediately you just
you you could like do something and you
know you failed and you still just have
to go through the entire
test knowing that you know no because in
australia the moment you fail they just
immediately tell you and they tell you
to drive back
because to the instructor they're like
oh sweet we finished 15 minutes earlier
i can take a break
so they changed the uk test from when
you did it now so when i had to do it
there was like a portion of it that was
with like a a
sat nav and then there was another part
where they were like telling me the
directions i hated it when they were
telling me directions oh yeah
and what what n why do i need to be
tested on this this is like testing my
ability to use like a quill
it's like i'm never going to use this
like just give me the little robot that
talks to you yeah
i can see where the map is i know what
the like i when you say write to me
it's 10 seconds before my brain goes
dumb it's like right
right right right now right now like
this this right like my right arm this
way
right like this my brain is like bruh
when i hear the directions
yeah i'm driving i'm like i'm trying to
change gear shut the [ __ ] up
no what they're testing you for is for
[ __ ] back seat drivers yeah yeah just
being like
right i'm like yo can you judge my
mixtape at least
can i get your thoughts
start playing all the [ __ ] anime
openings and everything
oh [ __ ] i love this opening all right
turn right oh my god
so yes so yeah so now i know not to go
to the [ __ ] dmv in japan thank you
for that thank you for taking the bullet
for us
now we don't have to hire a chauffeur
for trash days we just have you can't
wait to go tomorrow